je suis énormément harceler lyncher sur
les réseaux je n'ai pas du tout menacé
ni escroqué personne je n'ai pas fait
tout ça on vient me demander un service
que j'exécute et après on vient même axa
sur le dos non j'ai une famille j'ai des
enfants je peux pas me permettre
alors c'est 1,2 million d'euros c'est
c'est pas vrai cette somme là exactement
c'est pas ça j'ai pas les chiffres
exacts
c'est dans les locaux de voix mais ça
s'en rapproche
ça peut s'en rapprocher mais le chiffre
exact je n'ai pas viable à terme 1,2
million d'euros donc c'est donc que
c'est pas depuis quatre ans cyril 1 en
moi j'ai rencontré sept personnes en
2015 on est en 2021
c'est donc deux cent mille euros par an
pas moi qui vais demander un non mais je
d'accord vous axez parce qu'elle faisait
appel à vous donc c'est un bidule 2
millions d'euros guillaume genton moi
j'ai donné toute la somme incroyable
déjà est-ce que l'essor que vous auriez
jeter qu'on vous auriez demandé de jeter
les négatifs sont extrêmement violent
donc déjà avoué ce que vous avez une
éthique en tant que voyant pas ce que
vous accepter n'importe quoi de jeter
n'importe quel sort est deuxième
question les sommes qui sont évoqués
donc vous dites que c'est pas un million
de mecs ça s'en rapproche c'est des
sommes qui sont énormes peu de gens les
moyens de se payer ça vous saviez karl
avait beaucoup d'argent est ce que les
tarifs sont un peu à la tête du client
absolument pas pas du tout mais juste
qui justifie qu'on paye un million deux
cent mille euros par exemple m'ont donc
mais on ne paye pas comme vous dites un
million deux cent mille euros comme ça
d'un coup enfin il ya des années en
plusieurs fois
hmm hmm hmm 3000 euros cm non non pas du
tout non j'ai trouvé ce que c'est on
sait combien de ces enjeux
c'est pas des séances et c'est par
exemple un rituel qui va durer qui va
durer huit heures c'est combien pour 8
heures voilà que j'ai envie douala de
1903 1906 sud à tarif fixe abri dont ils
ont en 1908 arrivent au fur et à mesure
on est de faire de la voyance montmoreau
nous a dit hier que vous lui posiez des
factures en plus c'est vrai ça ça existe
des factures chez les voyantes
alors je n'ai jamais proposé de facture
elle me demandait et ça aussi je voulais
vous voulez vous payer sur sa société
nous a dit hier non et que vous l'avez
proposer du coup comme arrangement de
lui produire des factrices appareil je
peux aussi a testée et prouvée les
apporter les preuves et d'ailleurs les
enquêteurs les ont moi je n'ai jamais
proposé ces fameuses facture c'est elle
qui m'a demandé de faire ça justement
par rapport à cette fameuse société et
tous âges et les preuves je peux les
apporter juste il ya aussi
il ya eu des menaces qu'êtes vous
répondre aux accusations de menaces je
n'ai jamais menacé personne
enfin le voyez mon profil j'ai pas le
profil de quelqu'un qui va menacer qui
que ce soit je n'ai menacé personne à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui et je ne veux pas
continuer à me faire lyncher sur le sur
la place publique comme ça je ne mérite
pas d'être lynché à ce point là sur des
menaces je n'ai jamais menacé personne
benjamin qualité c'est alors qu'est ce
qui explique qu'aujourd'hui c'est là
qu'elle ressorte parce que du coup même
si vous êtes effectivement pas dans le
cas d'un chantage que vous avez fait des
prestations bon voilà c'est très fiable
non bon tant que ça va changer et qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui juste qu est ce qui
fait qu est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
cette affaire ressort avec les vidéos
l'épreuve avec avec une instruction
puisqu'il ya une enquête de police est
pas d'instruction parisien yves et la
brune vient une enquête dans tous les
cas ils inquiètent d'accord pourra
pourquoi à votre avis aujourd'hui cette
affaire ressort comme ça moi je moi je
comprends parce qu'il ya une base et
cette base il ya une base et cette base
malheureusement au vu de l' enquête
je ne peux absolument pas vous dévoiler
il ya un truc au dessus alors il ya
quelque chose d'accord il ya quelques
jours des problèmes c'est à dire il ya
quoi quelque chose mais sans nous
dévoiler type de quel ordre il ya
quelque chose qui fait que pour moi pas
pour moi parce que les faits sont là on
me met la menace de menaces en
maintenant on me met la menace
l'accusation de la menace l'accusation
de l'extorsion l'accusation de tout ça
parce qu'à la base il ya une base et moi
je n'ai jamais fait ça